how have you been
ah fantastic how have you been
i've been wonderful now i want to bring
up
a photograph and it's you and i
together when we first met it's a still
shot um from our movie that we did
together
back in 1988
um called see you in the morning and
that is when we first met and we played
stepbrother and step sister
yes and uh you know you haven't aged
since then nor have you
i'm so happy for you and your whole
family because right before we worked
together then you went and did home
alone and both of us
like went on to keep acting and living
our lives and
i remember your family also being around
the set um and you were a real family
operation which i really
loved and i just saw this great video
of rory and his cat
watching the show and he was telling us
and
me that he loves watching it and it
meant so much to me
yes so uh rory
and his wife sarah are huge fans of your
show
uh not to say that i'm not honestly when
football was on last tuesday
me and my lady we had a hard time
choosing between you
and football
[Laughter]
well that is the rock and hard place i
would like to be
between yes exactly i love
rory and we got to be in the scream
franchise together
and i love your brother kieran and you
know
i i really love yours and your brother's
journey and that we've all got to be a
part of it all of these years
and you've always been so kind and
i just think the world of you macaulay
you're such a
cool cat and by the way you are the most
talented amazing actor
and it is just always such a pleasure to
see you
and watch you and know you all of these
years
well thank you for having me this has
been a joy
and a blessing and all those kind of fun
things
and for real that outfit you're wearing
i want it
well i can send it to you and you look
rad by the way you're super cool wait
what is this
outfit your pants look really
interesting i don't know they're pajamas
no i shouldn't i work hands for you i'm
not kidding
those look like i would steal them from
you those look like my kind of pants i
would pair them with a rainbow sock
we should definitely wear the same socks
and paints i would like to say
a special thank you to rory
and sarah for watching this show
and i hope to live up to your tastes and
expectations of it
you have a wonderful brother with
macaulay and i love him oh so much and
i'm so excited that he was here today
hello to kieran too of course thank you
macaulay
thank you for being the big big big
surprise
on our show i am honored truly
thank you so much
you